Narrator:
THIS THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESSES.
WHAT I HAVE IN MY HAND
IS GOING TO ELIMINATE THE WORST
PART ABOUT DOING LAUNDRY.
UMANO
IS FASHION FOR GOOD.
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA
THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
BOOM!
[ LAUGHTER ]
...AND FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A DEAL.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU
$150,000 FOR 25%.
WHY CAN'T I GET A STRAIGHT
ANSWER FROM YOU?
Narrator: BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR...
Alex: OUR BIGGEST CHALLENGE
IS INVENTORY.
WE ARE MISSING OPPORTUNITIES.
...OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
I JUST LOVE YOU GUYS,
BUT IT HAS TO BE WORTH MY TIME.
I'M NOT GONNA WORK PART-TIME
FOR MY DREAM.
YOU HAVE
TWO DIFFERENT THINGS GOING ON.
PICK ONE BUSINESS
AND GROW THAT PART.
WHY?
THEY ALL MAKE MONEY.
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
DAYMOND JOHN DOMINATED
THE FASHION WORLD WITH FUBU.
NOW HE'S THE BRANDING EXPERT
BEHIND MULTIPLE GLOBAL BRANDS
GENERATING BILLIONS IN SALES.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
MORE THAN 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
ESTEEMED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
FIRST INTO THE TANK
IS AN ENTREPRENEUR
WITH AN IMAGINATIVE NEW
RECREATIONAL SPORT.
Radosta: HEY, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS JOHN ANTHONY RADOSTA,
AND I'M
THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER
AT ADVANCED SPORTS TECHNOLOGY.
I'M HERE SEEKING $160,000
FOR A 10% EQUITY STAKE
IN MY CORPORATION.
SHARKS,
ADVANCED SPORTS TECHNOLOGY
IS AT THE FOREFRONT
OF A NEW SPORT
THAT'S SWEEPING THE ENTIRE
NATION LIKE A TIDAL WAVE.
SHARKS, THIS IS THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF BUBBLE SOCCER.
[ WHISTLE BLOWS ]
[ LAUGHS ]
[ LAUGHTER ]
OH, MY GOD.
I LOVE IT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WE GOT TO TRY THIS.
[ WHISTLE BLOWS ]
UGH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
-OH!
-THEY CAN REALLY PLAY, TOO.
[ WHISTLE BLOWS ]
[ APPLAUSE ]
SHARKS, THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF BUBBLE SOCCER
ADDS THE ONE THING MISSING
FROM TRADITIONAL SOCCER --
FULL CONTACT.
-YOU CAN GET PHYSICAL.
-[ LAUGHS ]
-DELIVER SOME BIG HITS.
-OH, MY GOD.
AND FALL DOWN LAUGHING
LIKE YOU NEVER HAVE BEFORE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO, SHARKS, WHO'S READY TO
GET THE BALL ROLLING
AND CARVE THEIR NAME
INTO SPORTS HISTORY?
-CAN WE TRY IT?
-YEAH, CAN WE TRY?
-YES, ABSOLUTELY.
-I WOULD LOVE TO.
-COME DOWN.
-I WANT TO TRY.
COME ON OUT, ALL.
I'M KNOCKING YOU.
YOU GUYS ARE TOAST.
YOU'RE GONNA LOOP YOUR HANDS
THROUGH THESE FIRST.
-OH, I GOT IT.
-AND YOU'RE IN.
SHARKS IN THE BUBBLE.
CUBAN,
PUT THE BALL DOWN.
[ BOTH LAUGH ]
UGH! OH!
[ LAUGHTER ]
BOOM!
WHOO!
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ WHISTLE BLOWS ]
THAT WAS THE BEST.
THAT WAS THE ABSOLUTE BEST.
SO, JOHN, YOU'RE GONNA WALK US
THROUGH YOUR BUSINESS MODEL?
YEAH, SO ESSENTIALLY,
WE'RE THE ONE-STOP SHOP
FOR THE PERSPECTIVE BUBBLE
SOCCER ENTREPRENEUR
TO GET EVERYTHING THEY NEED
TO BE A PART OF THIS SPORT
AND PART OF
A SUPPORTIVE ORGANIZATION.
WE JUST LAUNCHED
OUR 40th AFFILIATE
THROUGHOUT
THE UNITED STATES.
SO ESSENTIALLY,
THEY RUN LEAGUES FOR US,
AND ESSENTIALLY,
WE WORK WITH THEM
AS AN EXCLUSIVE
EQUIPMENT PROVIDER
AND LEAD GENERATION PARTNER,
AND THEY'RE ACTIVELY
IN EACH CITY RUNNING LEAGUES.
WELL, FIRST OF ALL,
BEFORE YOU GET TECHNICAL,
'CAUSE HE DIDN'T --
DID YOU PLAY?
NO, I WATCHED YOU IDIOTS
BOUNCE OFF EACH OTHER.
-IT WAS FUN. IT WAS FUN.
-IT WAS A LOT OF FUN.
I DIDN'T THINK IT WOULD BE
THAT MUCH FUN.
THERE'S NOTHING ELSE LIKE IT.
IT REALLY IS.
Cuban:
THE BUBBLES WERE FUN,
BUT NO ONE CARED ABOUT
THE ACTUAL SOCCER, THE SPORT.
YOU MAKE A GOOD POINT.
SO THERE'S TWO TYPES
OF DEMOGRAPHICS
THAT PLAY BUBBLE SOCCER.
THERE'S
THE PRIVATE EVENT SIDE,
WHICH IS BASICALLY PEOPLE
JUST WANT TO GET IN THE BUBBLES,
TRY IT ONCE, CRASH INTO
EACH OTHER, HAVE SOME FUN.
THEN THERE'S ALSO
THE LEAGUE SIDE.
THERE'S THE LEAGUE COMPETITOR.
THEY'RE ACTIVE.
THEY'RE COMING BACK EVERY WEEK,
AND THEY'RE PLAYING IN GAMES.
AND HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE PLAYING IT TODAY?
WE'RE ALIVE
IN ABOUT 39 CITIES.
DEPENDING ON THE LEAGUE,
IT'S ANYWHERE BETWEEN
8 TO 12 TEAMS.
SO IF SOME OF IT IS EVENT
AND SOME OF IT IS THE LEAGUES,
HOW MUCH OF IT IS
FOR PRIVATE EVENTS, PARTIES,
THINGS LIKE THAT?
IT'S ABOUT
A 50/50 SPLIT.
BUT JOHN, FROM
A PROMOTIONAL PERSPECTIVE,
WE'VE RENTED STUFF
THAT'S SIMILAR.
WE DIDN'T INVENT THE SPORT
BY ANY MEANS.
WE SAW -- THE WAY
THAT I ACTUALLY GOT INTO THIS
IS I HAD SEEN SOME VIRAL VIDEOS
OVER IN THE UNITED KINGDOM
AND IN AUSTRALIA --
ARE THESE LEAGUES
EXISTING THERE?
YEAH.
HOW BIG HAS THIS GONE
IN EUROPE?
WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS ACTUALLY
THOSE LEAGUES ARE THRIVING
MORE THAN EVER.
DEFINE THRIVING.
JUST TO GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE,
I DON'T HAVE THE SEARCH VOLUME
FOR EUROPE OFF-HAND,
BUT JUST THE UNITED STATES,
IN 2014,
THE LARGEST NUMBER OF SEARCHES
PER MONTH IN GOOGLE
WAS ABOUT 55,000 SEARCHES.
IN 2015, IT GOT UP TO
85,000 SEARCHES.
BUT JOHN --
BUT DON'T TELL ME THE SEARCHES.
TELL ME THE SALES
IN EUROPE.
IT'S PRIVATE COMPANIES.
I DON'T HAVE DATA.
BUT YOU KNOW
HOW MANY LEAGUES THERE.
YOU DON'T KNOW
THE SALES IN EUROPE,
BUT YOU KNOW
HOW MANY TEAMS THERE ARE.
JUST IN ONE YEAR,
NOW WE'RE SEEING LEAGUES
POP UP IN
HONG KONG, TAIWAN --
NO, FORGET THE LEAGUES,
FORGET THE LEAGUES, JOHN.
-HOW MANY TEAMS ARE THERE?
HOW MANY TEAMS --
IT VARIES DEPENDING UPON
THE PARTICULAR SEASON, SO --
WHY CAN'T I GET
A STRAIGHT ANSWER FROM YOU?
O'Leary: I DON'T CARE
WHAT HAPPENS IN AUSTRALIA.
I'M INVESTING IN
THE UNITED STATES RIGHT HERE.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO GET
IN REVENUE THIS YEAR,
NEXT YEAR,
THE YEAR AFTER THAT?
HOW MUCH MONEY
ARE YOU GOING TO MAKE EACH YEAR?
SO WE'VE BEEN IN THE MARKET
FOR ABOUT 13 MONTHS.
THUS FAR, IN TOTAL SALES,
WE'VE DONE $355,867 IN SALES.
AND WHERE'S THAT REVENUE
COMING FROM?
YEAR ONE WAS EXCLUSIVELY
EQUIPMENT SALES,
HOWEVER, WE ALSO HAVE
A LEAD GENERATION
AND REFERRAL SYSTEM
THAT FUNCTIONS,
BASICALLY,
ON A COST-PER-LEAD BASIS.
WE'RE ON TRACK.
WE'VE STEADILY BEEN INCREASING
REVENUES, 38%, MONTH OVER MONTH.
GIVE ME THE DOLLAR.
WHAT'S THIS YEAR?
THE DOLLAR AMOUNT
IS $430,000...
THIS YEAR.
...THAT WE'RE PROJECTED
TO DO THIS YEAR.
HOW MUCH
YOU GONNA MAKE ON IT?
FREE CASH FLOW MARGIN'S 23%.
YOU'RE TELLING ME
$430,000,
YOU'RE GONNA
MAKE $80,000 ON IT, RIGHT?
FREE CASH FLOW, YES.
-WHAT ABOUT NEXT YEAR?
-THE YEAR AFTER THAT,
WE'RE EXPECTING ANYWHERE BETWEEN
$683,000 AND $742,000 --
SEE, BUT NOW YOU'RE JUST --
OKAY, OKAY.
-SO LET'S -- LET'S BE CLEAR.
-BUT YOU --
KNOWING YOUR NUMBERS
IS ONE THING,
BUT KNOWING YOU'RE JUST
PICKING NUMBERS OUT OF THE AIR,
JUST THROWING THEM OUT
IS --
YOU ASKED HIM THE FUTURE,
THOUGH. HE HAD --
I KNOW, I KNOW.
THE EVALUATION
THAT I PRESENTED HERE TODAY
IS BASED ON A DISCOUNTED
FREE CASH FLOW MODEL
WITH A DIMINISHING GROWTH RATE
OVER 60 MONTHS.
YOU'VE GOT TWO GUYS IN A BALL
BOUNCING AGAINST EACH OTHER,
AND YOU'RE DOING
DISCOUNTED CASH FLOW?
ABSOLUTELY.
JOHN, WHERE DO YOU SEE IT GOING?
DO YOU MANUFACTURE THE BUBBLES?
YES, WE MANUFACTURE
THE EQUIPMENT.
TELL US WHAT THE BALLS COST,
JOHN.
SO TOTAL-ENDED COST FOR US
IS ANYWHERE BETWEEN
$150 TO $160 PER BALL.
-WOW.
-OH, REALLY? WOW.
-WHAT DO YOU SELL THEM FOR?
TO THE END CUSTOMER, WE SELL
THEM IN FOUR DIFFERENT PACKAGES,
RANGING ANYWHERE FROM ABOUT
$4,000 TO ABOUT $16,000.
OH, SO THAT'S WHY YOU NEED
A LEAGUE, RIGHT?
IT'S AN INVESTMENT
IN A BUSINESS.
YOU'RE NOT SELLING THE BALLS
INDIVIDUALLY.
-NO.
-YOU SELL THEM AS A PACKAGE.
THIS IS SOMEONE INVESTING IN
A BUSINESS.
SO, JOHN,
I PAID YOU THE $4,000.
HOW MUCH MORE MONEY DO YOU MAKE
FROM ME OVER THE NEXT 12 MONTHS?
WE WORK WITH OUR AFFILIATES
IN A NUMBER OF WAYS.
WE OFFER OPTIONAL
EQUIPMENT PROTECTION PLANS.
YOU'RE PAYING ANYWHERE FROM
$90 A MONTH TO ABOUT $120
'CAUSE YOU ALSO HAVE
A COST-PER-LEAD,
SO IF WE SEND YOU FOUR LEADS,
IT'S $8 PER LEAD
THAT WE SEND YOU.
SO THE ONGOING REVENUE
IS FROM LEAD GENERATION.
IT'S FROM LEAD GENERATION
AND EXTENDED WARRANTY PROGRAM.
I FIND THIS
VERY CONFUSING.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, YOU HAVE
TWO DIFFERENT THINGS GOING ON.
YOU HAVE LEAGUES AND THEN
YOU HAVE EVENTS AND PARTIES.
SO WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
CATER TO THE MARKET
IN HOWEVER THEY WANT
TO EXPERIENCE THIS SPORT.
WHEN YOU DO IT
FOR THE PARTIES AND EVENTS,
WHAT DO YOU CHARGE PEOPLE
TO USE THEM FOR THE DAY?
A TYPICAL BIRTHDAY PARTY
WILL BRING IN ANYWHERE BETWEEN
$300 TO $500.
SORRY, JOHN.
DO YOU DO THIS DIRECT
OR DO THE LOCAL FRANCHISEES
DO THOSE?
THE LOCAL FRANCHISEES --
SO THEY ARE --
SO YOU DON'T MAKE MONEY
ON THE CORPORATE EVENTS?
NO.
-I DIDN'T REALIZE THAT.
-SEE, THAT'S THE KEY.
THE BULK OF JOHN'S SALES
ARE ONE-TIME.
JOHN,
I DID NOT REALIZE THAT.
HE DOESN'T CARE
WHAT THEY USE THEM FOR --
CORPORATE OR WHETHER
THEY'RE PLAYING A GAME.
IT ALWAYS BOTHERS ME
WHEN AN ENTREPRENEUR
COMES INTO THE SHARK TANK
AND IMMEDIATELY,
THE SHARKS TRY TO REDEFINE
THEIR BUSINESS MODEL.
THAT MEANS IT'S NOT CLEAR.
IT DOESN'T HAVE
ENOUGH OF A DEFINITION
IN TERMS OF PLACING CASH
BACK TO ME AS AN INVESTOR.
AND YOU WERE ALL OVER THE MAP,
YOU KNOW?
I STILL DON'T KNOW
HOW YOU EVER MAKE ANY MONEY.
YOU DID A REALLY POOR JOB
EXPLAINING IT TO ME.
SORRY. I'M OUT.
SURE.
YOU KNOW, I THINK THAT THIS IS
GREAT FOR THE CONSUMER.
I DON'T SEE THE VISION
FOR THE LEAGUES, SO I'M OUT.
JOHN, THE LONGER YOU TALKED,
THE MORE CONFUSING IT GOT.
THE LONGER YOU TALKED, THE MORE
BUSINESS MODELS THERE WERE.
IT FELL APART FOR ME.
I'M OUT.
THAT'S UNFORTUNATE TO HEAR,
BECAUSE ON THE TECH SIDE,
WE ACTUALLY HAVE A HUGE
TECHNOLOGY INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WE ACTIVELY
NEED SOME HELP MANAGING.
SEE, THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
NOW IT'S A TECH BUSINESS.
PICK ONE BUSINESS
AND GROW THAT PART.
WHY?
THEY ALL MAKE MONEY.
John: YOU CAN'T DO EVERYTHING
TO EVERYBODY.
I ACTUALLY HAVE TO
TAKE MY HAT OFF TO YOU
BECAUSE YOU'VE SCALED
PRETTY QUICKLY IN 13 MONTHS.
MY CHALLENGE IS
I DON'T THINK IT'S GONNA SCALE
MUCH LARGER THAN IT IS NOW.
YOU'VE DONE WELL WITH IT
TO THIS POINT,
BUT I THINK YOU'RE GONNA HIT
A BRICK WALL.
I'M OUT.
I DON'T SEE ANY BRICK WALLS,
BUT UNDERSTANDABLE.
MARK, IF THERE'S ANYBODY WHO CAN
HELP WITH SPORTS AND TECH,
I MEAN,
THAT'S OUR FOCUS HERE.
HERE'S WHAT I SEE.
YOU'RE NOT IN
THE SOCCER BUSINESS.
YOU'RE NOT EVEN
IN THE PRODUCTS.
YOU'RE IN THE BUSINESS
OPPORTUNITY BUSINESS, RIGHT?
WHAT'S KEY
IS YOUR AFFILIATES.
IF YOU WOULD HAVE COME IN HERE
AND SAID, YOU KNOW,
"WE HAVE AFFILIATES
IN 39 CITIES
AND THEY ALL
MAKE $25,000 A YEAR,
AND WE'RE GONNA
HELP THOSE AFFILIATES GROW
TO MAKE
$100,000 A YEAR EACH,
AND THAT'S GONNA BE
THE FOUNDATION
OF GROWING THIS LEAGUE,"
THAT WOULD HAVE TOLD US
WHAT BUSINESS YOU'RE IN,
BUT YOU WERE SO CONVOLUTED
IN TRYING TO SHOW US THE NUMBERS
AND HOW WELL
YOU UNDERSTAND THE BUSINESS,
YOU MISSED THE BASIC POINT
OF WHAT YOUR BUSINESS WAS.
IT WAS HARD TO UNDERSTAND.
I'M OUT.
WOW.
THAT'S SURPRISING.
-OKAY.
-NOT REALLY.
-REALLY?
YOU GOT FIVE PEOPLE
THAT AREN'T CLEAR ABOUT IT.
THANK YOU, GUYS, VERY MUCH.
CAN'T SELL THEM ALL.
VERY, VERY SMART SHARKS,
VERY SMART BUSINESSMEN,
BUT THEY DID
MAKE A MISTAKE TODAY,
AND WE ALL MAKE MISTAKES.
IT'S FINE.
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
ARE ENTREPRENEURS HOPING TO MAKE
A TRADITIONAL BRAZILIAN STAPLE
INTO A POPULAR AMERICAN SNACK.
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS JUNEA.
AND I'M CAMERON.
WE'RE THE HUSBAND AND WIFE TEAM
FROM PORTLAND, OREGON,
BEHIND BRAZI BITES.
WE'RE SEEKING
A $200,000 INVESTMENT
IN EXCHANGE FOR 10% EQUITY
IN OUR AWESOME COMPANY.
SHARKS, BRAZIL IS KNOWN FOR
ITS BEAUTY AND EXOTIC CULTURE,
BUT IT ALSO HAS
AMAZING FOOD.
I GREW UP IN BRAZIL,
AND ONE OF MY FAVORITE FOODS
IS BRAZILIAN CHEESE BREAD.
IT IS CRISPY ON THE OUTSIDE
AND FLUFFY INSIDE.
IT IS SO DELICIOUS,
YOU WOULD NEVER GUESS THAT
IT'S NATURALLY GLUTEN-FREE.
WHEN I MOVED TO THE U.S.,
I WAS SHOCKED.
I COULDN'T FIND IT ANYWHERE.
THIS BREAD IS TOO GOOD
NOT TO SHARE,
SO WE TOOK
JUNEA'S SECRET FAMILY RECIPE
AND DEVELOPED A PRODUCT LINE
THAT WE BELIEVE TO BE
THE BEST-TASTING, HIGHEST
QUALITY BRAZILIAN CHEESE BREAD
AVAILABLE ANYWHERE.
TODAY, WE HAVE
FOUR DELICIOUS FLAVORS
THAT GO STRAIGHT FROM
THE FREEZER TO THE OVEN
AND ARE READY TO ENJOY
IN MINUTES.
OUR CUSTOMERS
CAN'T GET ENOUGH.
-SO WHO IS READY TO JOIN US?
-BRING IT ON. LET'S GO.
OUR MISSION TO BRING
SOUTH AMERICA FLAVORS.
-GO. WE'RE HUNGRY.
-LET'S TRY IT.
-I'M DYING TO TRY.
YOU GUYS READY FOR SOME SAMPLES?
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
-THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
-DIFFERENT FLAVORS?
Cameron: DIFFERENT FLAVORS.
THERE'S FOUR FLAVORS THERE.
THEY'RE MARKED WITH TOOTHPICKS
FOR THE DIFFERENT FLAVORS.
OH, MY GOD.
THIS IS SO GOOD.
THE BACON?
RIGHT?
MMM, GARLIC ASIAGO.
Junea: SO, THE FLOUR THAT MAKES
THE BREAD IS TAPIOCA FLOUR,
AND IT'S NATURALLY GLUTEN-FREE.
OH, MY GOD,
THE PEPPER JACK IS SO GOOD.
-OHH!
-THESE ARE REALLY, REALLY GOOD.
-AMAZING.
-THANK YOU.
HOW MANY CALORIES?
SO, THE SERVING SIZE IS THREE
PIECES, AND IT HAS 120 CALORIES.
IT ONLY HAS
EIGHT INGREDIENTS.
MMM-MMM-MMM.
NO PRESERVATIVES,
NOTHING ARTIFICIAL.
CAN YOU COOK THEM
IN A MICROWAVE?
-NO.
-WHAT?
-BECAUSE WE SELL
AS FROZEN DOUGH,
YOU GOT TO BAKE IT,
BUT IT'S REALLY EASY.
IT'S STRAIGHT FROM THE FREEZER
TO THE OVEN.
IF YOU CAN BAKE FROZEN PIZZA
AT HOME,
YOU CAN MAKE BRAZI BITES.
IT'S THAT EASY.
HOW MANY STORES ARE YOU IN?
WE ARE NOW AVAILABLE
IN ABOUT 700 GROCERY STORES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WE ARE, FOR EXAMPLE,
IN WHOLE FOODS MARKET.
WE ARE IN
SPROUTS FARMERS MARKET.
AND HOW DID YOU
GET TO THOSE PEOPLE?
DO YOU HAVE SALES REPS?
CAMERON AND I
KNOCKED ON DOORS AND --
JUST POUNDING THE PAVEMENT
LOCALLY.
YOURSELF.
WHEN DID YOU
START THE BUSINESS?
Cameron: THREE YEARS AGO.
SINCE THEN, WE'VE TRIPLED OUR
REVENUE EVERY YEAR, BASICALLY,
SO IN 2013,
WE DID $60,000.
WE DID $200,000
THE YEAR AFTER THAT.
LAST YEAR, WE DID $600,000,
AND THIS YEAR, WE'RE ACTUALLY
ON TRACK TO DO OVER $1 MILLION.
WOW.
VERY IMPRESSIVE.
John: I'M TRYING TO SEE
WHERE I ADD VALUE.
YOU'RE ALREADY DOING AMAZING,
AND YOU WILL CONTINUE TO GROW
IN THE WHOLE FOODS OF THE WORLD.
BUT I BELIEVE THAT ONLINE,
YOU CAN GET FULL MARGIN.
-BUT I UNDERSTAND --
-SHIP IT FROZEN?
-YES, SHIP IT.
-HOLD ON, HOLD ON.
LET ME TALK FIRST.
BAD IDEA.
HERE'S WHERE
I BELIEVE I CAN HELP.
AL "BUBBA" BAKER.
I JUST DID A DEAL WITH HIM --
BUBBA'S BONELESS RIBS.
WE GOT TO REALLY MESS UP
TO NOT DO $200 MILLION.
HE'S DOING $25,000 A MINUTE
ON QVC.
HE'S WITH A GROUP CALLED
RASTELLI FRESH FOOD MARKET,
AND THEY SHIP GOODS,
LIKE OMAHA STEAKS.
MM-HMM.
THIS COMPLEMENTS
THE STEAK AND THE SEAFOOD
THAT ALL HAS TO BE SHIPPED
VERY TIME SENSITIVE,
FROZEN, NEXT DAY,
AND THEY ALREADY HAVE
A WIDE CUSTOMER BASE.
AND THERE,
YOU GET MORE MONEY
BECAUSE YOU'RE GOING
DIRECTLY TO THE CUSTOMER.
-SURE.
-MM-HMM.
BUT WHAT'S IT WORTH MY TIME?
I WOULD HAVE TO ASK FOR...
25% FOR $200,000.
IS THAT AN OFFER?
MATTER OF FACT,
THAT IS AN OFFER.
THANK YOU FOR THE OFFER, WE'D
LIKE TO HEAR IF THERE ARE ANY --
I WOULD DO THE DEAL
200K FOR 20%.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
Greiner: I'M SITTING HERE
THINKING ABOUT IT,
BECAUSE I DID A DEAL
LAST YEAR
WITH THE BANTAM BAGELS
STUFFED BAGEL BALLS, RIGHT?
MM-HMM.
IF YOU LOOK AT THIS,
IT LOOKS VERY SIMILAR.
I'M WONDERING
HOW THIS COULD INTEGRATE
WITH MY STUFFED BAGEL BALLS
OR IF IT'S COMPETITIVE.
STOP AND THINK
FOR A MINUTE,
AND TELL ME
WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN MY BANTAM BAGELS
STUFFED BAGEL BALLS AND YOU.
THE MAIN DIFFERENCE IS THAT
OUR PRODUCT IS GLUTEN-FREE.
YOU GOT IT.
THEIR'S IS A TRADITIONAL BAGEL
MADE WITH WHEAT.
-GOOD ANSWER.
-YES.
-RIGHT ANSWER.
-I WAS NERVOUS FOR YOU.
I'M GONNA OFFER $200,000 FOR
THE SAME 25% DAYMOND SAID.
OOH.
NICE STORY.
TOUGH OFFER.
LET'S HAVE SOME FUN.
I'LL DROP MY ASK TO
15% FOR THE 200K,
JUST TO
MAKE IT INTERESTING.
YOU'VE GOT KEVIN
GOING THE RIGHT WAY.
AND TO PUT SOME PRESSURE
ON THESE OTHER SHARKS.
GUYS, YOU'VE GOT A FEEDING
FRENZY FOR YOUR BRAZILIAN BITES.
Narrator:
ALL SHARKS ARE STILL IN,
BUT JUNEA AND CAMERON
HAVE THREE OFFERS ON THE TABLE
FOR THEIR BRAZILIAN
CHEESE BREAD, BRAZI BITES.
GUYS, YOU'VE GOT A FEEDING
FRENZY FOR YOUR BRAZILIAN BITES.
KEVIN, CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT
YOUR VISION FOR THE COMPANY?
YOU KNOW,
THE WAY I LOOK AT THIS IS
IT'S ONE-AT-A-TIME SALE
INTO PLACES LIKE
EVERY RETAILER THAT CARRIES
ANYTHING IN THE FROZEN CATEGORY.
Greiner: TO ME, I SEE YOUR REAL
HOOK RIGHT NOW, YOUR FIRST STEP
IS TO DOMINATE ALL OF THE
NATURAL AND ORGANIC FOOD PLACES
FIRST SO THAT YOU CAN
GET REALLY STRONG
AND MAKE YOUR BRAND KNOWN.
AND THEN WHEN YOU'RE FOUND IN
THE OTHER GROCERY CHAINS,
IT'LL BE RECOGNIZED.
John:
DO YOU HAVE DEBT ON THE COMPANY?
WE ACTUALLY HAD TO TAKE ON DEBT
IN ORDER TO BUILD OUT
OUR PRODUCTION FACILITY.
AND HOW MUCH DEBT
DO YOU HAVE NOW?
SO OUR DEBT ON THE BOOKS
IS ABOUT $200,000,
BUT WE'RE ACTUALLY
IN THE PROCESS
OF TRANSITIONING
OUT OF PRODUCTION.
AND WHEN WE DO THAT, WE'RE GONNA
SELL A LOT OF OUR EQUIPMENT,
SO WE'RE GONNA RECOUP
A LOT OF THAT.
WHY ARE YOU TRANSITIONING
OUT OF THAT?
DO YOU FIND A GREAT CO-PACK
OR A PARTNER?
YEAH, WE ACTUALLY HAVE
A CO-PACKING PARTNER
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
WORKING WITH, AND --
AND IS THAT PERSON GONNA OWN
ANY OF THE COMPANY, AS WELL?
THEY'VE MADE AN INVESTMENT
IN THE COMPANY.
HOW MUCH IS THAT?
WE HAVE A 50-50 PARTNERSHIP
WITH THEM.
-WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
-SO YOU --
Cuban: WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
THIS IS IMPORTANT.
YEAH, YOU GUYS OWN
50% OF THE COMPANY.
-CORRECT.
-YES.
Cameron: THEY MADE A MULTI-TIER
INVESTMENT THAT INVOLVED CASH,
A LINE OF CREDIT, AND THEY'RE
BUILDING OUT A FACILITY.
THEY'RE ORDERING
CUSTOM EQUIPMENT FROM BRAZIL.
Herjavec: HERE'S WHERE IT
KIND OF FALLS APART FOR ME.
I WISH YOU WOULDN'T HAVE
SOLD 50% OF IT.
-I DON'T KNOW THE OTHER PARTNER.
-MM-HMM.
THEY'RE NOT HERE
REPRESENTING ANYTHING.
AT THIS POINT IN THE GROWTH,
IT'S JUST NOT FOR ME.
I'M OUT.
-OKAY.
-THANK YOU, ROBERT.
THANK YOU, ROBERT.
I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
GUYS, LET'S JUST SAY
YOU MADE $25 MILLION.
BA-BAM, RIGHT?
FOR OUR 10%,
ONLY $2.5 COMES TO ME.
MM-HMM.
THE RISK-REWARD
HAS GOT TO BE GREATER.
NOW, THAT MIGHT SOUND CRAZY --
$200,000 TO $2.5 MILLION.
THAT SEEMS ENORMOUS.
BUT IT'S ALL RELATIVE
TO THE AMOUNT OF WORK INVOLVED.
SO EVEN IN
YOUR OPTIMAL SCENARIO,
IT'S NOT ENOUGH,
SO FOR THOSE REASONS, I'M OUT.
-THANK YOU, MARK.
-FAIR ENOUGH.
JUST TO ADDRESS YOUR OFFERS,
WE'D SAY THAT WE'D KNOW HOW MUCH
YOU GUYS BRING TO THE TABLE,
BUT 25% IS JUST
MORE THAN WE'RE CAPABLE OF --
Herjavec:
CAMERON, MAKE A COUNTER.
Greiner: SEE, THAT'S WHAT'S
INTERESTING THAT HAPPENS
WHEN YOU COME INTO
THE SHARK TANK
AND YOU'VE GIVEN AWAY 50%
OF YOUR COMPANY TO SOMEONE ELSE.
-IT'S A PROBLEM.
-RIGHT?
IT MAKES IT DIFFICULT
FOR YOU TO NEGOTIATE.
LORI, WOULD YOU MATCH
KEVIN'S OFFER FOR 15%?
WOW, YOU'RE NOT A SHARK.
YOU'RE CHOPPED TUNA.
O'Leary: JUST TO
MAKE IT MORE INTERESTING,
I'LL DROP MINE TO 12.5%.
SO, KEVIN, IN THAT CASE,
WOULD YOU JUST GO TO OUR 10%
AND GIVE US --
-YEAH, RIGHT.
-I'LL DO IT FOR 12.5%.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S WHAT HE DESERVED.
-I'LL DO IT RIGHT NOW AT 12.5%.
-OKAY.
John: BUT GUYS, THEY'RE NOT
BEING CREATIVE AT ALL.
THEY'RE NOT GROWING THE COMPANY
WITH THE STRATEGY.
WOULD YOU RATHER GO 12%
WITH KEVIN?
LORI, WHERE WOULD YOU GO?
GUYS, THEY'RE NOT GROWING
THE COMPANY WITH THE STRATEGY.
-LORI.
-I WOULD GO TO 20%.
-THAT'S BRUTAL.
-AND I DON'T --
THE PROBLEM IS IS I DON'T
WANT TO SQUEEZE YOU HERE.
YEAH.
I DON'T WANT YOU TO FEEL BAD
ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
YOU GAVE AWAY
50% OF YOUR COMPANY,
WHICH MIGHT BE A GOOD MOVE
TO A CO-PACKER.
IT WAS A GREAT DECISION, YEAH.
JUNEA, YOU'VE GOT TO
MAKE SOME DECISION.
IS THAT YOUR FINAL OFFER?
IT'S MY FINAL OFFER.
THAT'S AS LOW AS I'LL GO.
OTHERWISE,
IT'S JUST NOT WORTH IT.
-DAYMOND?
-I'LL GO TO 20%.
-I'LL MATCH LORI.
-ALL RIGHT.
SO TWO OFFERS FOR 20%,
ONE AT 12.5%.
I'LL GO TO 18%.
WOW.
HEY,
YOU GOT SHARKS ON DISCOUNT.
UM...
LORI WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO
DO THE DEAL FOR 15%?
OOH.
25% TO 15%.
I'M WORRIED.
DON'T BE.
THERE'S NOTHING
TO WORRY ABOUT.
IT'S A GREAT PRODUCT. YOU HAVE
GREAT ENTREPRENEURS HERE.
THIS IS
A SUCCESSFUL BRAND.
YOU ARE A SUCCESSFUL BRAND
ALREADY,
BUT YOU HAVE A LOT OF CHALLENGES
TO GO THROUGH, TOO.
-ABSOLUTELY.
-AND YOU'RE GONNA NEED --
A SHARK.
IT'S GONNA BE BIG.
18% I WAS AT,
AND YOU WANT ME TO GO TO 15%.
YES.
I'LL SPLIT THE DIFFERENCE.
$200,000 FOR 16.5%.
O'Leary: LET ME MAKE IT
MORE INTERESTING FOR YOU.
I'M OUT.
YEAH. I'M OUT.
LORI, YOU GOT A DEAL.
[ GASPS ]
THEY ARE DELICIOUS.
THAT REALLY PUSHED ME
OVER THE EDGE
BECAUSE FOR GLUTEN-FREE
TO BE THAT TASTY...
-OH, MY GOD.
-THANK YOU.
-IT'S AWESOME.
-THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
-THANK YOU.
-WE'RE STOKED.
-GREAT RECIPE.
-THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
-THANK YOU.
-OKAY.
John:
CONGRATULATIONS, GUYS.
THANK YOU.
Junea: WE WERE REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT LORI
BECAUSE SHE'S DONE GREAT THINGS
WITH CONSUMER PRODUCTS.
AND WE KNOW
THAT WITH HER HELP,
WE CAN MAKE BRAZI BITES
THE COMPANY
THAT INTRODUCES BRAZILIAN
CHEESE BREAD TO THE U.S.
Narrator: IN SEASON 6,
NEAL HOFFMAN MADE A DEAL
WITH LORI GREINER
AND ROBERT HERJAVEC
FOR HIS HANUKKAH TOY COMPANY,
MENSCH ON A BENCH.
Hoffman:
A MENSCH IS A DO-GOODER.
IT'S WHAT YOU WANT YOUR CHILDREN
TO GROW UP TO BE.
I LOVE THE IDEA OF
TEACHING GOOD VALUES AND MORALS.
$150,000 FOR 15%.
COME ON IN!
Narrator:
LET'S SEE HOW HE'S DOING NOW.
♪♪
Greiner: I INVITED NEAL
FROM MENSCH ON A BENCH
TO CHICAGO TODAY TO CHECK OUT
THE NEW MENSCH PRODUCT LINE
IN BED, BATH, & BEYOND.
-[ GASPS ]
-THIS LOOKS AWESOME.
WE DID SO WELL
LAST HOLIDAY SEASON
THAT WE NOW HAVE
AN ENTIRE MENSCH SECTION
IN 1,000 OF THEIR STORES.
WE HAVE MOSHE THE MENSCH,
A PLUSH DREIDEL,
AND A SINGING MENORAH.
I THINK WE'LL DOUBLE OUR SALES
THIS YEAR
JUST BECAUSE HE'S CUTE!
Hoffman:
ROBERT AND LORI RECOMMENDED THAT
I GIVE THE MENSCH A FACELIFT,
AND BOY, WERE THEY RIGHT.
WE'VE UPDATED HIS FACE,
MADE HIM MUCH FRIENDLIER,
AND I'M REALLY HAPPY
WITH THE OUTCOME.
I'VE BEEN WORKING WITH ROBERT
AND LORI FOR 10 MONTHS NOW.
I'VE SOLD ALMOST
$1 MILLION WORTH OF MENSCHES.
WE'RE GONNA CRUSH IT
IN 2015.
-YES.
-AND START 2016.
-ALL RIGHT. LET'S GO.
-LET'S GO.
I THINK IT WOULD BE GREAT
IF WE COULD MAKE
A STRONG FEMALE HEROINE FIGURE.
WE HAVE BIG PLANS
TO EXPAND THE PRODUCT LINE.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING TOGETHER
TO MAKE A FEMALE CHARACTER,
HANNAH THE HANUKKAH HERO,
WHO'S GONNA COME OUT NEXT YEAR.
MENSCH
IS A UNIVERSAL CONCEPT,
AND IF WE CAN HAVE MORE POSITIVE
IMPACT ON MORE CHILDREN'S LIVES,
THAT'S
OUR COMPANY'S MISSION.
Greiner: I INVESTED IN MENSCH
BECAUSE I LOVE THE MESSAGE
ABOUT A STORY
THAT'S GIVEN TO CHILDREN
THAT TEACHES THEM
HOW TO BE A GOOD PERSON IN LIFE.
Hoffman:
IT'S BEYOND WORDS TO THINK ABOUT
THIS LITTLE IDEA I HAD
TO BRING MY FAMILY TOGETHER
DURING THE HANUKKAH SEASON
IS NOW IMPACTING
SO MANY FAMILIES.
THANKS TO "SHARK TANK", THIS IS
GONNA BE A VERY HAPPY HANUKKAH.
Both: MAZEL TOV!
I'M JONATHAN TORREY.
AND I'M HIS BROTHER,
ALEX TORREY,
AND WE LIVE IN
ATHENS, GEORGIA.
OKAY,
LET'S TRY THE GUACAMOLE.
Alex: WE COME FROM A SUPER
TIGHT-KNIT MEXICAN FAMILY,
SO IT'S NO SURPRISE THAT
WE HAVE A BUSINESS TOGETHER
AND THE WHOLE FAMILY
PITCHES IN.
CAN I HELP?
WE'VE DEVELOPED A UNIQUE
FASHION BRAND CALLED UMANO.
WE KNOW THAT CLOTHING
IS A REALLY GREAT WAY
TO EXPRESS YOUR CREATIVITY,
AND WE WANT TO BUILD
A FASHION BRAND
THAT HAS A REALLY POSITIVE
SOCIAL IMPACT.
POPS, CAN YOU MAKE SURE
WE ORDER SOME MORE INK?
JONATHAN AND I HAVE PUT
EVERYTHING INTO UMANO.
WE MOVED BACK HOME
WITH OUR PARENTS.
WE SHARE A ROOM LIKE WE DID
WHEN WE WERE 7 YEARS OLD.
WE DID THAT WILLINGLY
BECAUSE WE REALLY BELIEVE THAT
UMANO HAS TREMENDOUS POTENTIAL.
WE'RE GONNA DO
TWO BLACK V-NECKS.
Man: YEAH.
-IS THAT RIGHT?
-WE'VE GOT THEM RIGHT HERE.
BECAUSE OF OUR MISSION,
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE
COUNTING ON US
THAT WE WANT UMANO
TO BE ABLE TO HELP.
BUT NOW, WITH INCREASING DEMAND,
WE'RE MISSING OPPORTUNITIES
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE AS MUCH
INVENTORY AS WE SHOULD.
Jonathan: WE HOPE THE SHARKS
WILL JOIN OUR MOVEMENT.
WHERE YOU CAN LOOK GOOD
AND DO GOOD.
♪♪
Jonathan: HI, SHARKS!
MY NAME IS JONATHAN, AND THIS IS
MY LITTLE BROTHER, ALEX.
WE'RE FROM ATHENS, GEORGIA,
AND WE'RE SEEKING $150,000
FOR 15% EQUITY IN OUR BUSINESS.
UMANO IS FASHION FOR GOOD.
WE DESIGN MEN'S AND WOMEN'S
ELEVATED FASHION BASICS
WITH A PERSONALIZED MEANING
TO CONNECT PEOPLE
TO A BIGGER PURPOSE.
THE AWESOME ARTWORK
YOU SEE HERE IS CURATED FROM
SOME OF THE MOST AMAZING
UP-AND-COMING ARTISTS --
KIDS!
SHARKS, MEET JESSICA.
SHE DREW THE SKULL
AND WANTS TO BE A TEACHER.
Cuban: HOW OLD IS SHE?
SHE'S 7.
[ LAUGHS ]
WEARING UMANO IS A BADGE OF
PRIDE, AND IT'S A PLEDGE,
BECAUSE WITH EVERY PRODUCT
YOU PURCHASE,
UMANO WILL GIVE A BACKPACK
FULL OF SCHOOL SUPPLIES
TO EMPOWER
YOUNG CREATIVE MINDS.
INVESTING IN UMANO
MEANS THAT
YOU DON'T HAVE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
DOING WELL AND DOING GOOD.
SO WHO WANTS TO
TAKE A RIDE WITH US
ON THIS ELEPHANT,
THE TINY DANCER,
DRAWN BY
5-YEAR-OLD EMANUEL.
OR THIS BIKE, THE FIX-E, DRAWN
BY FUTURE FIREFIGHTER RUBEN.
[ CHUCKLES ]
WE HAVE HAND-PICKED SOME OF OUR
FAVORITE DESIGNS TO SHOW YOU,
AND WE'LL SHARE THEM
WITH YOU NOW.
-YES, SIR.
-THANK YOU, JONATHAN.
YOU'RE VERY WELCOME.
-THANK YOU.
-HERE, MR. WONDERFUL.
-THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
-YOU ARE VERY WELCOME.
THANK YOU.
IT'S REALLY NICE.
FEELS SOFT.
Alex:
WE HAVE TRAVELED THE WORLD,
LITERALLY, TO GET THAT FABRIC.
FIRST OF ALL, HOW MUCH IS IT,
AND HOW DO I BUY IT?
THOSE SHIRTS THAT YOU HAVE,
THEY START RETAILING AT $48.
WE ARE SOLD
AT BLOOMINGDALE'S.
WE ARE SOLD AT SPECIALTY STORES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AND THROUGH OUR WEB SITE.
DOES IT HAVE THE CHILD'S PICTURE
HANGING AT BLOOMINGDALE'S?
YES,
THE WAY IT'S HANG-TAGGED
IS WITH THE HANG-TAG
THAT YOU CURRENTLY SEE ON IT.
John:
DOES THE CHILD OR THE PARENTS --
DO THEY GET A ROYALTY?
Alex:
SO, THE WAY IT'S STRUCTURED NOW
IS THAT WE HAVE
A REALLY GOOD RELATIONSHIP
WITH ALL OF
OUR PARTNER SCHOOLS.
WE GIVE THE BACKPACKS
FULL OF SCHOOL SUPPLIES,
COLLECT THE DRAWINGS,
COME BACK TO ATHENS, GEORGIA,
TO CREATE THE ARTWORK.
SO AS THE BRAND EXPANDS,
WE WILL EXPAND THE GIVING.
CAN I ASK -- IS THIS A BUSINESS
OR IS THIS IS A CHARITY?
WE ARE A BUSINESS 100%.
SO YOUR PURSUIT
IS FOR PROFIT.
THE CONCEPT OF SOCIAL
ENTREPRENEURSHIP IS TO USE --
Cuban:
THE WORLD HAS CHANGED, RIGHT?
THE LAST FIVE YEARS, RIGHT?
WHEN PEOPLE ARE WALK IN,
PARTICULARLY MILLENNIALS,
THEY DON'T JUST WALK IN
AND BUY A PRODUCT.
THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
THEY WALK IN
AND BUY A CAUSE.
BUT TO SUSTAIN IT,
YOU'VE GOT TO MAKE A PROFIT.
-WELL, NO, THEY GO HAND-IN-HAND.
-WE DO.
WE HAVE THE MARGINS
TO DO THAT.
Herjavec:
THE T-SHIRT IS $48.
-YES, SIR.
-WALK ME HOW MUCH YOU PAY FOR IT
AND THEN HOW MUCH THE GIFT BAG
COSTS THAT GOES BACK.
-RETAIL $48.
-OKAY.
THE COST OF THE PRODUCT, $7.
THE BACKPACK AND SCHOOL SUPPLIES
IS $4,
SO WE LOAD UP TOTAL
AT $11.
WE HAVE A 48% MARGIN-PLUS.
WHERE ARE THESE SCHOOLS?
ARE THEY IN COUNTRIES OF NEED?
Alex:
WE HAVE SCHOOLS EVERYWHERE.
WE HAVE PARTNER SCHOOLS
OVERSEAS,
IN PLACES LIKE MEXICO AND PERU,
WHERE WE MANUFACTURE IN HAITI,
BUT ALSO RIGHT HERE AT HOME
IN ATHENS, GEORGIA, FOR US,
LOS ANGELES,
HARLEM, NEW YORK.
WHAT WERE YOUR SALES
LAST YEAR,
AND WHAT WILL YOU DO
THIS YEAR?
LAST YEAR,
WE SOLD $106,000.
THIS YEAR, WE'RE SCHEDULED
TO CLOSE AT $250,000.
GETTING INTO BLOOMINGDALE'S
IS SO HARD.
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
IT'S NOT JUST GETTING INTO
BLOOMINGDALE'S,
BUT THE DOORS WE'RE IN.
WE'RE IN 59th STREET,
WE'RE IN SOHO,
WE'RE IN
THE FLAGSHIP STORES.
THE REASON WE GOT IN
IS BECAUSE OF THE STORY.
DO YOU GUYS HAVE
ANY INVENTORY RIGHT NOW?
-WE DO.
-OKAY, HOW MUCH IS THAT?
8,000 UNITS.
Alex:
THOSE 8,000 ARE ALREADY SOLD.
DO YOU PLAN TO BE
A T-SHIRT COMPANY OR --
WHAT'S THE FULL EXPANSION
OF THE LINE?
WE ABSOLUTELY WANT TO BE
A LIFESTYLE BRAND,
AND WE CAN ACTUALLY SHOW YOU A
PREVIEW OF OUR SPRING '16 LINE.
SURE.
OH, THAT'S COOL.
THESE ARE DRESSES, THESE
ARE ROMPERS, THESE ARE LEGGINGS,
HOODIES, ZIP-UP, AND THAT'S
JUST ON THE WOMEN'S SIDE.
O'Leary: GUYS, LET'S SAY
YOU GET TO $10 MILLION IN SALES.
DO YOU THINK THERE'S ANY RISK
THAT PEOPLE WILL TURN AROUND
AND SAY,
"LET ME GET THIS RIGHT.
THE CHILDREN GET A BAG
WORTH 4 BUCKS.
YOU GUYS ARE NOW MAKING $4
MILLION A YEAR IN PROFIT,
PRE-TAX."
IT'S CHILD LABOR.
I MEAN, I COULD SEE A
NEGATIVE STORY DEVELOPING HERE.
-THAT'S A STRETCH THERE.
-THAT'S --
-KEVIN!
-IT'S DEFINITELY NOT.
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
THE BIGGER BRANDS CAN'T GO IN
AND DO WHAT WE'RE DOING --
THIS IS GRASSROOTS.
-JONATHAN AND I --
-WHY? WHY CAN'T THEY DO THAT?
BECAUSE THEY'RE THE ONES
THAT ARE GONNA BE UNDER
-THE GREATEST MICROSCOPE.
-CORRECT.
IT'S AN IMPORTANT POINT
FOR US TO MAKE
THAT AS THE BRAND GROWS,
WE WILL GROW THE GIVING.
Herjavec: I THINK THE DESIGNS
ARE BEAUTIFUL,
AND I APPLAUD YOU
FOR THE CAUSE.
I AGREE WITH YOU
THAT PEOPLE TODAY
CARE ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE BUYING
AND WHY THEY'RE BUYING.
ABSOLUTELY.
SO YOU'RE REALLY A DESIGN
COMPANY WITH A GREAT CAUSE.
TOUGH BUSINESS, BECAUSE
DESIGNS ARE LIKE RESTAURANTS --
SOMETHING'S HOT TODAY,
IT'S NOT HOT TOMORROW.
I SEE A LOT OF RISK.
I'M OUT.
-THANK YOU.
-THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
-YEAH.
-AND ON THAT NOTE,
AS YOU GUYS
HAVE ALREADY MENTIONED,
FOR US,
MILLENNIALS ARE EXPANDING.
BY 2018, THEY WILL SURPASS
THE PURCHASING POWER
OF BABY BOOMERS, AND THOSE --
OUR FAVORITE BRANDS
ARE BEING DISCOVERED RIGHT NOW.
O'Leary:
GUYS, LET ME TAKE A SHOT AT IT.
LOOK, IT'S VERY CREATIVE
AND IT'S GOOD-LOOKING STUFF.
WE'VE SEEN
A LOT OF T-SHIRTS
COME THROUGH
THE "SHARK TANK" DOOR.
THIS IS DIFFERENT.
THERE'S NO QUESTION
ABOUT IT.
BUT IT'S EMBRYONIC.
MAYBE YOU CAN FIND A SHARK
THAT WANTS TO
START YOUR JOURNEY HERE.
I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S NOT ME.
I'M OUT.
-THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
-THANK YOU.
WHAT'S HOLDING YOU GUYS BACK?
WHAT CAN WE ANSWER?
YOU SAID THE 8,000 UNITS
WERE ALREADY SOLD.
WHERE ARE THEY GOING?
TO FULFILL THE BLOOMINGDALE'S
ORDERS UNTIL DECEMBER.
AND YOU DON'T HAVE THE MONEY
TO GO OUT AND SOURCE MORE.
Alex: CORRECT. OUR BIGGEST
CHALLENGE IS INVENTORY,
AND WE'RE
MISSING OPPORTUNITIES.
BLOOMINGDALE'S
IS ASKING FOR MORE DOORS.
WE CAN'T DO THAT.
Greiner: YOU GUYS ARE SCRAPPY,
YOU HAVE A COOL LOOK.
I LIKE ENTREPRENEURS THAT ARE
WILLING TO DO WHATEVER IT TAKES.
YOU GUYS
SEEM THAT WAY TO ME.
-THANK YOU.
-AND I LIKE YOUR MISSION.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU AN OFFER.
I'M GONNA GIVE $150,000
BUT FOR 25%.
YOU KNOW,
YOU'RE JUST STARTING.
THERE'S A LOT OF DESIGN WORK TO
DO, THERE'S MORE SOURCING TO DO.
I THINK THAT I CAN HELP YOU
A LOT WITH THAT.
-THANK YOU.
-SO THAT'S MY OFFER.
-THAT'S AN AMAZING OFFER.
-CONGRATULATIONS.
-WE REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
-YOU GOT AN OFFER.
DO YOU ACCEPT IT?
THERE ARE TWO MORE SHARKS. WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN --
John: HERE'S WHAT I'M GONNA DO.
I MEAN, YOU KNOW,
I'VE BEEN IN THIS BUSINESS
FOR QUITE SOME TIME.
I HAVE MAYBE ONE BRAND
IN BLOOMINGDALE'S,
AND I HAD TO BEG
TO GET THERE.
WE DID A LOT OF BEGGING.
SO I HAVE TO CONGRATULATE YOU
ON THAT.
I WOULD HAVE TO OFFER
THE 150K FOR 33.3%.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR OFFER.
-YOU NOW HAVE TWO OFFERS.
-AND HERE'S WHY I WANT THE 1/3.
IT'S GONNA BE
ALL THREE OF US WORKING AT IT.
I JUST KNOW
I BRING A DIFFERENT SKILL SET.
AND THOSE ARE TWO AMAZING OFFERS
AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
JONATHAN AND I
HAVE WORKED THREE YEARS,
-GIVING EVERYTHING WE HAVE.
-BUT, WAIT.
YOU HAVE ANOTHER SHARK.
YOU STILL HAVE MR. CUBAN.
CORRECT. SO WE WOULD LOVE
TO HEAR FROM HIM.
I LOVE
WHAT YOU GUYS ARE DOING.
REALLY WHERE YOU NEED THE HELP
ISN'T IN THE SALES.
-YOU NEED CREDIT, BASICALLY.
-CORRECT.
-AND YOU NEED ONLINE HELP.
I'LL MAKE AN OFFER
OF 150K FOR 20%.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE OPTION.
IF LORI WANTS TO COME IN
OR DAYMOND WANTS TO COME IN,
THAT'S FINE
JUST BECAUSE IT'S A GOOD CAUSE.
BUT I'M HAPPY
TO DO IT BY MYSELF.
-I'D GO IN WITH YOU.
-DAYMOND, ANY INTEREST?
I HAVE NO NEED FOR NON-CLOTHING
INDIVIDUALS IN MY DEAL.
O'Leary:
WHAT AN INTERESTING SITUATION.
DAYMOND JOHN,
WHO'S THE FASHION GURU,
WANTS TO BE
AN EQUAL PARTNER.
HE'S OFFERED YOU $150,000
FOR 33.3%.
MARK AND LORI, WHO DON'T HAVE
THE SAME EXPERIENCE IN FASHION,
ARE WILLING TO GIVE YOU THE SAME
AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR ONLY 20%.
THIS IS ONE OF THE RARE TIMES IN
"SHARK TANK" HISTORY
WHERE TWO SHARKS ARE ASKING FOR
LESS EQUITY THAN ONE.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
IT'S LITTLE BROTHER'S CALL.
DAYMOND, WE REALLY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR OFFER.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
PROTECT SOME OF THAT EQUITY
SO THAT WE CAN RAISE MORE MONEY
IN THE FUTURE.
WE WOULD LOVE TO MAKE A DEAL
WITH MARK AND LORI.
-AW!
-SO WE HAVE A DEAL?
-WE HAVE A DEAL.
-DONE.
AWESOME.
-PLEASURE.
-I CAN'T WATCH TO SEE YOU.
-APPRECIATE IT.
-I WILL GET YOU HOOKED UP.
-OH, I LOVE IT!
-OH, MY GOD.
[ LAUGHS ]
O'Leary: EW.
THANK YOU, GUYS.
I'M KEEPING THE SHIRT.
-YES, IT'S ALL YOURS.
-THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
Greiner: CONGRATS.
Jonathan:
THROUGH OUR JOURNEY,
WE'VE PROBABLY HEARD
100 NOs TO ONE YES.
Alex: 100,000 NOs.
SO THESE YESES REALLY HELPED NOT
ONLY BUILD OUR OWN CONFIDENCE
BUT ALSO THE TEAM'S
THAT WE ARE ON THE RIGHT TRACK.
Narrator:
NEXT UP IS A SOLUTION TO
A PERSISTENT HOUSEHOLD PROBLEM.
♪♪
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS
TRACIE BURRESS.
AND I'M GLEN BURRESS.
-AND WE'RE SEEKING $50,000...
-$50,000.
...INVESTMENT FOR 20% EQUITY
IN OUR COMPANY.
WHAT I HAVE IN MY HAND
IS GOING TO ELIMINATE THE WORST
PART ABOUT DOING LAUNDRY.
BUT FIRST, I WANT TO
SHARE WITH YOU A LOVE STORY
ABOUT A LOVELY SOCK COUPLE
NAMED SAL.
OH, LORD.
...AND SALLY TUBESOCK.
I LOVE SOCK PUPPETS.
THEY HAD
A WONDERFUL RELATIONSHIP.
ONE DAY, THEY WENT IN
FOR THEIR WEEKLY WASH,
GAVE EACH OTHER A LONG
PASSIONATE KISS GOODBYE.
Both: MWAH!
[ GIGGLES ]
HANG ON, MY LOVE.
THIS RIDE COULD GET ROUGH.
I'LL SEE YOU
ON THE OTHER SIDE.
-OH, THIS IS HORRIBLE.
-[ LAUGHS ]
SAL AND SALLY BOTH WENT INTO
THE WASHER AND DRYER TOGETHER,
BUT UNFORTUNATELY,
ONLY SAL CAME OUT.
-OH, NO!
-NO!
[ LAUGHTER ]
SINCE SAL HAS JUST LOST
HIS "SOLE MATE"
TO THE DREADED
SOCK MONSTER.
AND NOW
SAL IS FORCED TO JOIN
THE LONELY, SINGLE,
MATELESS SOCK CLUB.
SOCKTABS WILL MAKE SURE
THAT EVERY SOCK
CAN KEEP TABS ON ITS MATE
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
LAUNDRY PROCESS.
HERE'S HOW IT WORKS.
ONE SOCKTAB STAYS ON ONE SOCK
AT ALL TIMES,
THAT WAY YOU WEAR IT
THROUGHOUT THE DAY,
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY,
YOU SIMPLY PINCH THE WINGS,
TAB IT THROUGH ITS MATE,
AND YOUR SOCKS ARE READY
TO GO INTO THE HAMPER...
Both: TOGETHER.
INTO THE WASHER...
TOGETHER.
AND WHEN YOU
OPEN UP THAT DRYER,
YOUR SOCKS, GUESS WHAT,
COME OUT...
TOGETHER!
[ GIGGLES ]
Greiner:
ARE YOU HANDING OUT SAMPLES?
YES.
Herjavec:
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO, TRACIE,
DOESN'T THIS HURT?
Tracie:
YOU REALLY DO NOT FEEL IT.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
ONCE YOU PUT IT ON,
YOU DON'T FEEL IT.
O'Leary: SO,
WHAT ARE YOUR NUMBERS LIKE?
WHAT DOES IT COST YOU
TO MAKE A PACKAGE?
WHAT DO YOU SELL IT FOR?
WHAT ARE THE MARGINS?
Glen:
OKAY, A PACKAGE OF 24 IS $1.25.
ABOUT $1.25
FOR US TO MAKE IT.
WE SELL IT TO OUR WHOLESALERS
AT $4.99.
Herjavec:
HOW MANY HAVE YOU SOLD, TRACIE?
TO DATE,
AND WE JUST STARTED,
'CAUSE THIS IS NOT
A PRE-REVENUE SITUATION --
HERE WE GO.
WAIT FOR IT.
UH-OH.
THIS IS AN EARLY-REVENUE
SITUATION.
SO TO DATE, WE'VE SOLD JUST OVER
$20,000 IN ABOUT MAYBE...
-SIX MONTHS.
-RIGHT.
THAT'S NOT BAD.
HOW HAVE YOU SOLD IT?
THROUGH WHICH CHANNELS?
FIRST OF ALL,
JUST GOOD, OLD-FASHIONED
EVERY SINGLE RETAILER
IN ROCKFORD, ILLINOIS,
THAT I HAVE PURSUED
WITH SOCKTABS,
THEY'RE ALL CARRYING IT.
SO YOU'RE CALLING THEM
ONE AT A TIME?
SO, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
LET ME GET THIS STRAIGHT.
IN ROCKFORD, ILLINOIS,
YOU'VE SOLD $20,000.
ABSOLUTELY. THIS IS
WHAT I'M TRYING TO TELL YOU.
-WELL, SOME ARE ONLINE.
-WE HAVE ONLINE SALES, AS WELL.
OKAY,
HOW MUCH ARE ONLINE?
ABOUT 60% IS RETAIL,
40% ONLINE.
Greiner: LISTEN.
I LOVE YOU GUYS,
BUT I KNOW PEOPLE THAT SELL
THINGS THAT PUT SOCKS TOGETHER.
OKAY.
THERE'S AT LEAST
FIVE, SIX BRANDS
-I CAN THINK OF RIGHT NOW...
-REALLY?
...WHERE -- YES, THERE ARE.
I KNOW.
-YOU KNOW WHAT?
-I KNOW BECAUSE I HELPED THEM
WITH A LITTLE BIT
OF THEIR MARKETING.
WE HAVE NEVER SAID
THAT THERE WAS NO COMPETITORS
OUT THERE, LORI.
THE DIFFERENCE
WITH OUR PRODUCT
THAT YOU GUYS
REALLY NEED TO UNDERSTAND --
THIS HAS A DUAL PURPOSE.
THE DUAL PURPOSE IS THAT IT
CAN A FASHION ACCESSORY, OKAY?
-FASHION.
-A FASHION ACCESSORY?
BECAUSE IT'S LIKE
A CUFF LINK FOR YOUR SOCKS.
-CUSTOMIZABLE.
-SO THINK ABOUT IT.
-TEAM COLORS.
-WE CAN PUT TEAMS ON HERE.
-TEAM LOGO.
-TRACIE, YOU ARE A HUSTLER.
-I AM.
-YOU ARE 100%.
I'M FROM THE SOUTH SIDE,
AND I BELIEVE IN MY PRODUCT.
MY PROBLEM HERE IS
I KNOW PEOPLE THAT MAKE VERY
COMPETITIVE PRODUCTS TO THIS.
I THINK IT WOULD BE A CONFLICT
FOR THIS BUSINESS RIGHT NOW.
I HAVE TO BE OUT.
Herjavec:
TRACIE, YOU KNOW,
I THINK PEOPLE HAVE BOUGHT
A LOT OF THIS PRODUCT
BECAUSE OF THE POWER
AND UNIVERSE OF TRACIE.
I BELIEVE THAT.
I THINK
YOU COULD SELL ANY PRODUCT.
YOU KNOW WHAT? YOU'RE GIVING ME
A LOT OF CREDIT.
TRACIE, LOOK, I'M GONNA LET YOU
FOCUS ON THE RIGHT SHARK.
I'M NOT THE RIGHT SHARK
FOR THIS DEAL.
I DON'T REALLY HAVE A PROBLEM
IN LOSING SOCKS.
I DON'T SEE ME
PUTTING THIS IN MY SOCKS.
AMERICA DOES.
ANYONE THAT HAS FEET.
AND THERE'S A COMPETITIVE
PRODUCT. I'M OUT.
THAT'S 'CAUSE ALL OF HIS SOCKS
ARE DIFFERENT COLORS
AND DIFFERENT STYLES
AND DIFFERENT PATTERNS.
-LET'S TAKE STOCK.
-I'M OUT!
SO, GUYS,
HOW DID YOU GET HERE?
WHAT'S YOUR BACKGROUND?
WELL, I'M A PRODUCT OF
THE INNER CITY OF CHICAGO.
I'M THE VERY FIRST PERSON OUT OF
ABOUT 27 OF MY FIRST COUSINS
TO ACTUALLY GRADUATE
FROM COLLEGE.
I'M NOW
A PHARMACEUTICAL SALES REP.
I'VE WON THE PRESIDENTIAL AWARD
RESERVED FOR ONLY THE TOP 7%.
YEAH!
WHAT ABOUT YOU, GLEN?
SAME THING --
RAISED ON THE SOUTH SIDE,
MY MOTHER WORKED TWO JOBS TO PUT
MY SISTER AND I THROUGH SCHOOL.
WENT TO NORTHWESTERN, UNIVERSITY
OF ILLINOIS MEDICAL SCHOOL,
UNIVERSITY OF CHICAGO
FOR RESIDENCY,
AND NOW I'VE BEEN IN
PRACTICE 19 YEARS.
WOW.
John:
HERE'S WHERE I'M AT.
IT'S VERY HARD
FOR ME TO DO THIS DEAL
BECAUSE IF MY BOMBAS SOCKS GUYS
FOUND I WOULD DO THIS,
THEY WOULD BEAT ME SO HARD
THAT I'D BE
HOOKED ON PAINKILLERS
-FOR THE REST OF MY LIFE.
-CAN I STOP YOU RIGHT THERE?
ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE WANT TO PURSUE
IS TO GET A LICENSING DEAL WITH
A SHOE OR A SOCK MANUFACTURER.
I KNOW THAT YOU ARE --
YOU HAVE A SOCK --
YES,
BUT YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
LOSING SOCKS IS WHERE WE MAKE,
YOU KNOW, OUR BUSINESS.
Tracie:
WHAT WE WANT YOU TO DO IS
MAINTAIN THE SOCKS
THAT YOU ALREADY HAVE.
YOU KNOW HOW MANY MOMS
ARE AFRAID TO SPEND $20
ON THEIR 12-YEAR-OLD?
NOW THEY DON'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT IT.
GUYS, I GOT IT.
LISTEN. I GOT --
YOU KNOW
THOSE FASHIONABLE SOCKS
THAT THEY'RE WEARING WITH
THE FLIP-FLOPS?
SOCCER SOCKS!
GUYS, I'M SORRY.
I LOVE YOU, BUT I'M OUT.
NO, DAYMOND.
OKAY.
ALL IS NOT LOST, TRACIE.
MARK'S STILL IN.
-SO IS KEVIN.
-I AM, THAT'S TRUE.
I WISH YOU HADN'T
BROUGHT THAT UP.
CAN YOU IMAGINE
A MICKEY MOUSE?
OKAY, YOU GUYS
ARE KIND OF THINKING
THAT
I'M A LITTLE AGGRESSIVE.
NO.
THREE YEARS AGO,
I HAD A BRAIN ANEURYSM.
I WAS AIRLIFTED
FROM ROCKFORD, ILLINOIS,
TO NORTHWESTERN HOSPITAL
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT,
FOLLOWED BY
AN 11-HOUR BRAIN SURGERY.
AND I CAN ASSURE YOU
THAT GOD BROUGHT ME BACK
STRONGER AND MORE FEISTY
THAN EVER.
MARK. KEVIN.
ARE YOU IN? ARE YOU OUT?
Narrator: THREE SHARKS ARE OUT.
TRACIE AND GLEN ONLY HAVE
TWO MORE CHANCES
TO GET A DEAL FOR THEIR COMPANY,
SOCKTABS.
MARK. KEVIN.
ARE YOU IN? ARE YOU OUT?
GUYS, LOOK. I DON'T WANT TO
BE IN THE SOCKTAB BUSINESS.
THAT'S JUST THE HONEST-TO-GOD
TRUTH, RIGHT?
YEAH.
THERE'S NO WAY I CAN
MATCH YOUR PASSION ON THIS.
AND THAT'S ALWAYS A PROBLEM,
RIGHT?
I DON'T NEED YOU
TO BE THE ENTREPRENEUR.
LET ME DO THAT.
I JUST NEED AN INVESTMENT.
-WELL, LOOK.
-I NEED THE INVESTMENT.
GOING OUT
AND GETTING $50,000,
I DON'T THINK
THAT'S YOUR STUMBLING BLOCK.
I THINK YOU WANT
SOMEBODY WHO CAN MATCH
YOUR DESIRE
TO BE SUCCESSFUL
THAT CAN BE THERE
WHEN YOU NEED THEM, RIGHT?
YOU'RE JUST GONNA BE
A FORCE OF NATURE.
I DON'T THINK
I CAN BE THERE FOR YOU.
I'M OUT.
Greiner: SO ONE SHARK LEFT.
O'Leary:
TRACIE, WHAT I DON'T LIKE --
YOU'RE NOT FULL-TIME
ON THIS DEAL.
YOU'RE DOING IT AROUND YOUR JOB,
WHICH IS VERY LUCRATIVE, ONE,
IF YOU'RE A SUCCESSFUL
PHARMA REP.
YOUR HUSBAND IS A DOCTOR.
HE'S BUSY.
WHO'S TAKING CARE OF
THE SOCKTABS?
THERE'S NO FULL-TIME PERSON.
IT'S AN IDEA, IT'S A PRODUCT.
-IT'S NOT A COMPANY.
-YOU KNOW WHAT, KEVIN?
SO THAT'S AN ISSUE.
I WILL DO
WHATEVER I NEED TO DO.
EVERYTHING THAT'S HAPPENED
TO MY LIFE
HAS PREPARED ME
FOR THIS MOMENT,
AND I'M NOT GONNA WORK
PART-TIME FOR MY DREAM.
NO, BUT LOOK --
I CAN ASSURE YOU
OF THAT RIGHT NOW.
I DON'T THINK BUSINESS
CAN EVER REPLACE THE INCOME
THAT YOU'RE MAKING
AS A PHARMA REP,
'CAUSE
I THINK I KNOW WHAT THAT IS.
-THAT'S A BIG NUMBER.
-IT'S A GOOD NUMBER.
AND I DON'T THINK YOU SHOULD
DO THAT TO YOUR FAMILY.
AND I WOULD NOT
PUT THAT IN JEOPARDY.
I'M SORRY.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, GUYS.
-ALL RIGHT.
-I APPRECIATE IT.
-THANK YOU, GUYS.
-THANK YOU.
-GOOD LUCK, GUYS.
-BYE.
-THANK YOU.
TRACIE.
I'LL GIVE YOU $50,000 FOR 30%,
IF MY BOMBAS GUYS AGREE.
ARE YOU OKAY WITH THAT?
COME ON.
OF COURSE.
-WELL, LOOK AT THAT.
-ALL RIGHT.
-AWW.
-THANK YOU SO MUCH.
-I APPRECIATE IT.
-AND DIDN'T WANT TO WALK OUT.
I REALLY DO.
I FEEL YOU.
-ALL RIGHT.
-THANKS, MAN.
-THANK YOU.
-APPRECIATE IT.
WE JUST NEEDED SOMEBODY
TO SEE OUR VISION,
AND FORTUNATELY, AT THE LAST
MOMENT, DAYMOND SAW IT.
AND THAT'S
WHAT WE WANTED ANYWAY.
WE REALLY WANTED DAYMOND.
-[ LAUGHS ]
-YES.
ALL THAT HARD WORK.
-I KNOW.
-WOW. MAN.
♪♪